[Music]
i'm william dennis a product manager for
gke autopilot
i'm excited to introduce a new mode of
operation for google kubernetes engine
that we think you will like if you're
new to kubernetes it's the industry
standard way to deploy
and manage application containers making
it efficient to develop and publish
internet-based applications
gke was the first managed kubernetes
service to the market over five years
ago
and remains the most scalable and
reliable platform with an
industry-leading 15 000 node capability
and it's brought to you by a team that
makes more technical contributions to
the kubernetes project
than any other company kubernetes gives
you a container application platform on
which to run your services
what does it actually take to run this
platform there's quite a lot of aspects
from the control plane provisioning and
management
to worker node creation and patching
since its launch
gke is taking care of most of these
elements for you but there are a couple
of things that were still your
responsibility like configuring and
managing node pools
we figured that what you really care
about most is running your own
applications and services on gke
and not the configuring and monitoring
of the compute that they run on
so we looked at what more we could do to
help that's why i'm happy to introduce
gke autopilot a new mode of operation
for gke
with autopilot the node configuration
and management is now our responsibility
as well
so you can focus more on your own
applications and services that run on
top
with autopilot everything is auto
provisioned
all you need to do is name the cluster
pick a region set the network
and deploy your workload with kubernetes
and once things are provisioned
google is responsible for managing the
nodes and keeping them running
when it comes to the bill you pay for
pods and not vms
let me drill into each of these a little
further i mentioned that with autopilot
we have auto provisioned everything what
this means in practice
is that your pod and deployment
configuration is also the complete
cluster specification
we provision compute resources based on
the resource needs you specify in your
podspec
there's minimal cluster setup with no
need to figure out what size and shape
of nodes should be provided for your
workloads
we also apply all the latest security
best practices automatically you've
already been able to offload many
cluster operational responsibilities to
google
and now this applies to nodes as well
and since we're now managing the nodes
they're more locked down which also
serves to prevent accidental or
intentional modifications
that can cause issues even with us
managing everything you can still use
features like maintenance windows and
pod disruption budgets
to govern how and when updates occur in
fact
we're so confident of our management of
this new platform that we're offering a
pod level sla in gke for the first time
this sla offers three nines of uptime
for pods running in multiple zones
the other major difference is how you
build since you now specify your
resources at a pod level
that's how you build as well your pods
are built per second for vcpu
memory and disk resource requests system
components
the operating system overhead and most
importantly unused capacity
is no longer your concern once you scale
a workload down the associated charges
cease immediately
gke's free tier includes autopilot
giving you one free zonal or autopilot
cluster
so you can give it a try and just pay
for the pods you deploy despite being
fully managed
gke autopilot is still gke and supports
nearly the full gamut of workload
capabilities
workloads requiring stateful set and
even daemon set are supported at launch
and more support is on the roadmap we
think you shouldn't have to compromise
when it comes to your kubernetes
application platform
and built autopilot with that in mind
from the outset we said to ourselves
that
autopilot is gke and we want you to hold
us to that
popular administrative workloads from
our partners in areas like logging and
monitoring
are either supported now or on the
roadmap basically the only workloads we
don't expect to be compatible with this
new mode of operation are custom
administrative workloads that might be
used for low-level node management tasks
exactly the kind of thing which we hope
won't be needed in autopilot
and one more thing we've actually been
running a private preview for a few
months
and are pleased to announce that
autopilot is launching as generally
available
and ready for your production workloads
with that i'd like to take you through a
quick demo of what autopilot can do
to create an autopilot cluster all you
need to do is give it a name
pick your favorite region and set the
network
if you have any particular networking
requirements in my case i'll leave the
network as the default public cluster
and click create creation takes a couple
of minutes so let me switch to one i've
created earlier
to connect to this cluster i click the
connect button and copy the connection
command to my clipboard
now from the command line i'll paste
that command to authenticate cube cuddle
so i can access the cluster the demo i'm
going to deploy today is from the gke
sample repository
so let's clone that repository from
github and change into the sample
directory
finally i'm going to apply the
kubernetes configuration of the yes book
sample
now this sample consists of a php
front-end with a redis back-end
now if you've deployed redis before
you'll be aware that does have a few
resource requirements
in the past you may have had to
configure no pools to ensure that they
have enough capacity
but with autopilot we do that for you
this takes about a minute to provision
so i'm just going to skip ahead
[Music]
let's go ahead and grab the ip address
of this sample application
and check it out so i pasted that ip
address into my
browser loaded it up and i can give it a
quick test
and that was autopilot with the
introduction of autopilot
gke is now available in two modes of
operation standard
and autopilot standard is the experience
that we've been building since the
launch of gke where you have full
control over the nodes
with the ability to fine tune things to
your heart's content for example running
custom administrative workloads
and even tweaking the node operating
system itself
autopilot is a hands-off fully managed
solution that empowers you to focus on
your workloads while we take care of the
rest
both modes of operation are generally
available and fully supported by google
cloud
so please choose whichever best suits
your needs to learn more about autopilot
please follow this link to g.co
[Music]
autopilot